preliminary coalition talks have begun
in germany after parliamentary elections
on sunday two smaller parties the greens
and the market friendly fdp
met late on tuesday annalina berbach of
the greens posted this photo to
instagram last night she said the two
parties were already focusing on finding
common ground it's likely they will both
enter government as king makers but it's
not yet clear which of the bigger
parties they will team up with olaf
schultz from the social democrats says
he has mandate to govern after his
party's narrow victory he hopes to begin
talks this week but the leader of the
conservatives amin lascit insists he
also will try to form a government
our political correspondent julius
saudelli joins us now for more on this
julia the king makers in this election
the greens and the fdp uh they started
to sound each other out what can we
expect from these talks
as we've seen from that instagram photo
that all four of um those politicians
posted with a very similar
text underneath saying they're looking
for compromise and building bridges and
it seems like
they are managing to achieve that they
are in talks right now and are working
to find that common ground that is very
much needed between these two parties
because they do not necessarily have so
many points in common some issues that
could come up could be related to their
different approach to tax policy their
different approach to financial policy
and
debt to finance investment and and so on
but there are also some points where
they might be able to find things in
common for example on foreign policy
they both want to be uh harder on russia
and china they're both focused on human
rights also on uh pushing the digital
development of the country this is a
point they're both pushing upon so it
will be very important for these two
parties to find agreement then be able
to move on and talk um to the spd or to
the cdu possibly
talking about the cdu a number of
conservatives are now openly accepting
their defeat in this election what's
going to happen to their leader their
chancellor candidate amin lashed
well it's a big open question at the
moment what is going to happen to la
[ __ ] there is certainly
not a lot of
necessarily support in the party for him
at the moment not only within the cdu
but also within
its sister party in bavaria the csu
which is led by maku soda marco cerda
who was a con
contendent with la chat for the role of
chancellor candidate for the
conservative union and
i'm sorry sirda himself has said that he
doesn't really see a mandate to form a
government right now and other people uh
within the conservative union have said
uh the same so it's a lot will depend on
whether lashed is able to maintain his
standing within the party uh if then
the cdu will go into talks with the
greens and the fdp if talks with the
social democrats end up failing
a lot of people are wondering julio
where is chancellor mackel she hasn't
said anything since the election
well if we think about it uh chancellor
mackel was also quite quiet uh before
the election she hadn't really gotten
involved in the campaign with amin
lashed until the poll started showing
that the cdu wasn't performing very well
and only then did she start going to
some campaign events supporting nashet
she was present on election night at the
cdu
headquarters but
now she's going to stay on as chancellor
until a new chancellor
is
found but we
are likely going to see her stay quiet
in terms of commenting the election
results also because it's hard to
imagine that she's satisfied with how
the cdu performed
chancellor merkel settling into her role
as caretaker chancellor julia thank you
very much julius siddali our political
correspondent there